let's go back to John Craig who as you
know I was just discussing the issue
with and John what are you hearing
anything more about this it's a real
development here a huge development only
a few minutes ago I was talking about
the fears among senior politicians that
the Prime Minister's condition was more
serious than we were being led to leave
this is well like when was a Prime
Minister last in intensive care and
we've heard about Churchill during the
war getting ill and so on
but this is dramatic just to recap for
anyone who may not have heard it number
10 has said in the last minute or so
since I was last talking to you at
Dermott since Sunday evening the Prime
Minister has been under the care of
doctors at San Thomas's Hospital who
also after being admitted with
persistent symptoms of coronavirus over
the course of this afternoon the
condition of the Prime Minister has
worsened
so that was presumably before mr. Robb
was speaking in Downing Street at five
o'clock and on the advice of the medical
team his medical team he's been moved to
the intensive care unit at the hospital
the Prime Minister has asked Dominick
Robb first secretary of state to
deputize him when for him where
necessary the PM is receiving excellent
care and thanks all NHS staff for their
hard work and dedication so the
number-10 of work we got well we
understand that the PM was moved into
the intensive care unit a short time ago
around 7:00 p.m. so that is within the
past hour or so the decision was made
apparently by the medical team and when
his condition worsened and we as we've
heard he's asked mr. Robb to deputize
for him well this is dramatic news and
real a real escalation of the crisis if
you like at the top of government a
prime minister in the midst of a real
medical crisis of pandemic who is in
intensive care